foreign
was always chasing Pope Benedict XVI he
was already 78 years old when he took on
the role in academic a social
conservative the first German Pope for a
thousand years
[Music]
prison to exploit the wisdom of a long
life
now acclaimed by his own successor
foreign
and we feel such gratitude in our hearts
gratitude to God for having given him to
the church and to the world from around
the world expressions of Sorrow from
politicians and religious leaders
I heard a lovely comment from Rome just
a few days ago when one of the people
there said as as Pope Benedict's Health
declined so rapidly he said the angels
are gathering to carry him home and
that's what we know today and we ask God
to receive him gratefully because he was
a very faithful servant of the Church of
Christ throughout his life
in 2010 benedict made the first ever
official papal State visit to the UK
welcomed by crowd of adoring pilgrims
before meeting Queen Elizabeth and
giving dozens of sermons
today King Charles paid his own tribute
writing I remember with fondness my
meeting with his Holiness during my
visit to the Vatican in 2009
I also recall his constant efforts to
promote peace and Good Will to all
people and to strengthen the
relationship between the global Anglican
community and the Roman Catholic Church
but Benedict's visit to Britain also
showed the other side of his papacy
criticism that he wasn't doing enough to
address sexual abuse allegations within
the church
the number one challenge for Pope
Benedict Was the abuse crisis which was
just gaining it in in in speed and
spreading all over the world during his
pontificate and he did take several
steps to begin to respond to that but
his critics say that he he didn't do
enough in the in the time that he was
the pope
Benedict may be best remembered for the
way he left the stage shocking the World
by retiring from a job that most assumed
only ended with death
his final address sounded weary
it was a journey with joy and light but
there have also been difficult moments
he said goodbye to his Cardinals but
stayed in the Vatican living in a
converted monastery
and ushering an era when the world had
two men who'd both been named as Pope
his successor Pope Francis will lead
Benedict's funeral on January the 5th
that was a remarkable step he made and
there hadn't been a pop since the Middle
Ages though who stepped down so he as a
fairly conservative person was also
opening a door
to a world of today where people need
not to stay in office until they die
he was the quiet academic Who lit
controversial rows a man known for
leading and then leaving the pope who
walked away from his job
and who is now mourned by millions Adam
Parsons